[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be talking about
Jeff Bezos today and our thoughts on him
and let's go ahead and jump right into
it so as you guys know Jeff Bezos is now
the richest man in the world and he
recently had a really powerful interview
in Washington DC and I was watching that
and I was realizing how much I actually
respect a lot of the way that he carries
himself and what he's building into the
world and I think we hear a lot in the
news about things that are going really
badly for so many people that work with
Amazon but rarely do we hear about all
the great success that it's bringing so
let's go ahead and unpack this in the
nuance and in the detail so all right
the first thing that I think is really
important to mention this is an image
from the Economic Club in DC where he
just had that conversation it was a
really really good hour-long fireside
chat highly recommend watching it and
the first thing that I noticed from
watching Jeff here was that he
frequently referenced heart and
intuition
along with science and I think that when
someone openly talks about heart and
intuition I think that showcases some
vulnerability that showcases some
ability to tap into energy that is not
necessarily following the scientific
method so and this is kind of these
subjective perceptions and I think these
are really important to highlight these
feelings these emotions what it feels
like to go from intuition that type of
stuff so I think it's very powerful that
Jeff Bezos was openly talking about that
along with science in the whole process
of things so as you guys know okay so we
have now you know richest man worth over
a hundred billion dollars sure Amazon's
market caps now over a trillion dollars
you know one of the first things that he
was doing here that I thought was really
interesting as well is with this with
the interlocutor that was talking to him
they were poking fun at like Jeff like
what happens when your credit card gets
the kind just like I just use my other
credit-card and they're just like you
know making fun of of him you know being
wealthy in this case and he was playing
along with it and that kind of stuff and
I think that's really important to be
able to do to not distance yourself but
rather embody it and embody sort of the
humor around these types of things so
okay so now check this out he quoted him
see this is a quote for him he said that
I've made over eight hundred and sixty
billion dollars of wealth for other
people I think that's really important
to highlight here and understand is that
not only do you as an Amazon Prime
member get access to an inventory of
millions of items at the click of a
button shipped to your doorstep in two
days which we gotta be so grateful for
that but also the fact that now over
eight hundred and sixty billion dollars
of wealth has been created for other
people over the last 20 years that
Amazon has been around that's a lot of
wealth created for other people that's a
lot of products delivered in two days
for people around the world so these are
just important things to remember as we
have a nuance driven conversation around
Jeff Bezos so if you guys remember this
this photo here is from the og days of
Jeff Bezos in his office in the late 90s
building Amazon and this is so funny
because this is like what a lot of
startups look like it's so accurate
there's just you know a dude behind a
desk or a chick behind a desk on a
computer building something that they
think is powerful that they think is
really important to them that they think
other people are going to really like to
enjoy something of high value to society
and so this is these are the tough days
when you look at an image like this it
is when someone you know he left a hedge
fund in New York City to build Amazon
and it was a really funny story because
you know he met his you know their wife
McKenzie there at the hedge fund and
then just this general idea that
everyone was calling him crazy that he
he understood that the most of our
regrets in life are from the paths that
we didn't get to travel down and so the
path that he wanted to travel down that
he thought that he would regret would be
never becoming an entrepreneur
and he did here and we always talk about
that on the show has become an
entrepreneur go and create
entrepreneurship to the best thing
you'll ever do and so by taking big
risks like this you have a very high
likelihood of getting a reward if you
are very intelligent about how you go
about things a lot of startups also fail
though but anyway just coming back how
funny this is there's this you know
spray-painted amazon.com sign in the
background it's just very funny and it's
also very indicative of what really hard
work over 20 years does enough with the
instant gratification economy bs we have
been building simulation for a year and
I'm not fretting anymore about oh my
gosh we don't have these crazy insanely
success metrics of followers and money
and all this stuff I'm over it
it's been a year this is what happens in
20 years you build a trillion-dollar
company it doesn't happen overnight so
you got to really hustle your ass off
for 20 years to be able to see your
fruits to see the value that you've
brought to the world at these grander
scale so really have long-term vision
and long term
delayed gratification as you just pursue
your passion he pursued it in the
Internet era most people don't know this
but the reason why Amazon became the
started the way it did was because Jeff
saw that a bookstore could only have a
hundred fifty thousand books at most but
at anytime there's three million books
in circulation so he thought I'm gonna
make a catalog of all the books
available on the internet and anyone can
just go and click a button and get that
book delivered to them and Jeff would go
and pack up the books himself and drive
them to the store and so it's just a
very you know you got to be on the
ground scraping the gum doing the hard
[ __ ] when it first starts and then you
got to respect other people that join
your team the actually kevin O'Leary was
recently talking about this as well and
I really respect him a lot as well as
just the notion that once you have
customers customers are number one year
number two once you have employees
employees are number two you're number
three once you have shareholders they're
up number three and you're number four
so it's customers employees shareholders
are all above the entrepreneur the CEO
and that's really important to remember
they are the priority not you you are
building a business your business is the
priority something that you're building
with value that goes past you and past
impacts so anyway so he solved that
problem and then he started selling
books passed books he went to music he
went to videos he went to electronics he
went to toys and as you see here this is
an image of the warehouse and in this
amazon fulfillment warehouse they not
only have all these toys and electronics
and books and all this different stuff
but they have some of the world's
leading technology that enables the
warehouses and the logistics to operate
seamlessly this has been very very
difficult to design an engineer and I
just want to put a lot of attention on
this because it's not easy to have
massive distribution warehouses massive
amounts of inventory knowing where they
get coordinated and moved once someone
buys it across the world and so here's
one aspect of the technology I think is
really important these little orange
boxes that you see underneath of the
blue stacks that are moving those are
what are called Kiva robots these robots
will go to the different areas in the
warehouses when an order gets placed and
they will go and bring the stack of
goods that is placed to the packager so
without getting so much into the
distribution logistics just imagine how
insanely complicated it is to run all
these variables to have robots and
humans working cohesively and shipping
the products in two days to people
across the world this is very impressive
stuff and we need to be very grateful
that this exists with the click of a
button
all right a lot of people also aren't
familiar with Amazon Web Services they
offer a massive cloud computing service
that is a lot of their revenue and so
just Amazon Web Services are used by a
lot of people so definitely check them
up they can probably be very useful for
your business and they're very useful
for so many people's businesses so again
thank you greatly for Amazon Web
Services being around as well so he also
announced that he has a philanthropic
gift at this at this fireside chat that
he had in Washington DC
a two billion dollar philanthropic gift
for early education and for homelessness
and so again baseless doesn't know
exactly how much of his wealth he's
gonna give away he's really focused on
Blue Origin which we're gonna get to
after we talk about Whole Foods in
Washington Post but he is slowly giving
away things like this two billion dollar
anthropic gift for early education where
she cares a lot about and he had this
very powerful quote of this is something
that we're writing about right now in
our book time is that the notion that
the compounding effect occurs on a
child's mind if the child is - if
they're three years olds if they're four
years old and they're learning these
really powerful themes about art music
and writing and language and culture and
science and math and history and just
getting all these things at young ages
it compounds over the entirety of their
life so that's what he cares a lot about
early education and homelessness is very
important to Seattle just like it is in
San Francisco in LA in New York we have
a lot to work out here in this country
okay so moving on now we're gonna just
quick right before we get to Whole Foods
I want to talk about the customer
centric approach jeff has been hammering
this in over and over again in his
conversation that Amazon focuses on the
customer and I mentioned that over time
about this ranking system but focusing
on the customer and the customers needs
are crucial by doing that you that's how
you build a community that's how you
build value that's how you show them
that you care about them first and so he
did these things like you would send a
survey out to a thousand of his
customers and say hey what would you
want us to sell next on Amazon and
people would just tell him oh I want you
know my bike or I want this or that and
so people would tell him what they're
looking for next akin kitchen supplies
and in warehouse spices and all this
different stuff so he just started
understanding that he should sell as
much stuff as he could that he has two
different distinct ways of seeing things
he called people either missionaries or
mercenaries and I really like this
understanding a mercenary is someone
that is kind of like a megalomaniac
someone that's just trying to get there
for power greed money fame that type of
stuff and then a missionary someone
that's building the vision building the
impact and building it purposefully
because it gives them meaning
Society meaning in value and you can
totally feel the difference in a human
being when you approach them and you see
which one they're focused on which one
are they focused on and so really tap
into that intuitive heart energy that
feeling you get from someone when you're
with them are they doing this as a
mercenary or are they doing this as a
missionary which one okay let's move on
to Whole Foods so Whole Foods is this is
an insanely large acquisition that
occurred and it I believe it was yeah
like a twenty six billion dollar
acquisition it was a it was a huge
acquisition and so I want to do to do
Whole Foods on acquisition I want to
know the exact price I think that was
right no it was 13.7 billion it was it
was a Microsoft bought LinkedIn for
twenty six billion and Amazon bought
Whole Foods for thirteen point seven
which is a massive acquisition it's a
huge number fourteen billion dollars is
a lot of money and the reason why this
acquisition happened in my opinion is
because I think that Jeff Bezos very
intelligently knows that he sells right
now Amazon consists of 40% of all online
sales are through Amazon but he has less
than 1% of the world's physical sales so
he knows that he wants to get into the
physical sales market and what better
way to do so than by acquiring a value
centric a purpose centric grocery chain
like Whole Foods and so now what's
happening is as Jeff Bezos is building
out these cash earless stores so by
there's gonna be three thousand Amazon
go cashier 'less stores by 2021 and this
is a massive whoo this is a job
retraining alert we have so many of
these job retraining alerts on this show
this one is probably one of the most
powerful ones ever is guys the cashiers
the stalkers the the employees at
grocery stores and need to be retraining
today they should have been retraining
yesterday we need to retrain into new
positions into new skill sets into
artistic creative critical thinking
skill sets that are not repetitive work
because that work is being automated and
it is gone it's gonna be gone
in a decade so please get retrained we
talked about that so much so and one
last one last aspect about this that's
really fascinating is that we're moving
into an instant delivery economy so now
it's gonna be these really high powered
drones that are delivering you the one
item that you need in 30 minutes after
you click the button and it's absolutely
nuts that we're moving in that direction
and places like Whole Foods become
another logistics center like the Amazon
warehouses are so you can now have Whole
Foods be this sort of logistics center
for taking goods and delivering them
locally to the people that need them the
most so it's a very interesting
acquisition and food is something that
people get three times a day most often
and grocery something they get once a
week or however often so this is a big
deal for an acquisition of around
fourteen billion dollars ok next up is
the washington post acquisition this is
another huge one washington post amazon
acquisition the amount was 250 million
so alright 250 million is a lot less
than 14 billion so that's actually a
quarter of a billion dollars so now i
know it's nowhere near as much but it's
not chump change i still glow to money
and so this is this is coming at an
interesting time because his acquisition
of the washington post now we're looking
at marc benioff the CEO of salesforce
acquiring time so what is going on with
a 'quack position of magazines and
newspapers why is this important to
billionaires and this is just a very
interesting space I really highly
recommend we keep an eye on this space
because whatever is going on in it
requires our attention because why is
this outreach having global outreach
through a newspaper outlet having
readers so now Jeff in this case has
readers of Washington Post as his
customers he has his Amazon Prime
members that want people to that you
want to deliver goods in two days he has
Whole Foods customers now that go and
shop at these local grocery stores so
now you see where this is going you know
his readers he has on e-commerce he has
physical stores so this is the idea is
where why are people shopping for these
newspaper outlets and these
magazine outlets welfare readers and for
eyeballs and so what does this mean for
the future so let's keep an eye on the
space as we move forward Jeff has a very
high I like how he scrutinizes he says
if you're gonna become an entrepreneur
if you're gonna become a political
figure if you're gonna become anything
in this world that requires scrutiny
you're gonna you're gonna have that
happen to you and you need to be ready
for that scrutiny because this isn't a
walk in the park it's not even even I
get scrutiny all the time on these
common threads of people like Alan's
like horrible he's not good he's bad
whatever and I really think to myself
I'm like thank you for your feedback cuz
I want to know what I'm not good at I
want to know what to get better at I'm
not gonna cry wide and get upset I'm not
gonna tell you to stop commenting and so
that's what I think is weird about the
current media situation as people are
getting called out for you know fake
news and for all this type of stuff but
really I think it's really important to
understand that you need to be willing
to be scrutinized by no matter what
outlets it is in order for you to
understand what you can do better and
what and this is kind of what Jeff Bezos
is giving scrutinized in some ways by
people I don't know enough information
about the about the in sensitivities to
employees and in sensitivities regarding
employee pay inside these warehouses
versus what goes on in the corporate
headquarters it seems like people are
doing really well in the corporate
headquarters versus the warehouses I'm
not sure about it but what I but what
its scrutiny is important to dig out the
transparency get the facts out there so
we can really figure out what's going on
in the most nuance driven way possible
and how do we can best build the future
so so and let's okay so now we're gonna
end we're gonna end on on Blue Origin so
we have Jeff's space company Blue Origin
is this is approaching a billion dollar
per year budget and I think that's very
important to understand how much money
is being put into Blue Origin to make it
successful and why Jeff is doing it so
the reason why Jeff is building Blue
Origin is because Jeff sees the next
generation of space infrastructure as
the most important thing for Humanity
because we are approaching
in many ways a decision are humans going
to become static on earth and just stay
in our own dynamic state but in stasis
on earth half somewhere around nine
billion people just living on earth and
using the energy here and staying here
or are we going to go and leave Earth go
to the moon go to this outer in Earth
orbit around Earth are we gonna go to
Mars are we gonna call an eyes are we
gonna go to our solar system and I think
that that vision is really important
Jeff said he said this was really
interesting he said that if we had a
trillion humans living in our solar
system
he said that we would have thousands of
Einsteins and beethoven's and stuff like
that and I was like hmm is that actually
could that actually be true and what
would that look like if we had a bunch
of leading male and female leaders
across art music and entrepreneurship
and all these other fields that we
wouldn't necessarily have because of our
limited amount of population the limited
amount of brains that get to evolve and
hearts that get to evolve souls to get
evolved on the planet so I like that
understanding and he also made it very
clear that Amazon was built on the
transportation business the
communications business the internet
business the credit card business and so
he built Amazon on top of that
infrastructure so now he wants to open
up space infrastructure to make it so
young entrepreneurs can build the next
generation companies on top of his space
infrastructure so that view is in itself
a very giving back sort of view and I
like that I like his mission around that
and so overall Jeff Bezos seems to me to
be a good guy speaks about heart and
intuition along with science he
understands that you know he took his
risk with Amazon and he has achieved
great success and he's giving back to
with philanthropic efforts giving back
with building out this next generation
of space infrastructure with Blue Origin
and he's working on big projects with
Whole Foods and Washington Post is
exciting stuff now in terms of the
nuance around employees that work in in
the distribution centers and how to best
treat them how to best pay them all that
kind of stuff totally down to hear your
thoughts in the comments I'd love to
become more enlightened about how we can
drive more nuanced conversation around
that
I really appreciate you all tuning in to
this episode of thoughts on Jeff Bezos
has been a lot of fun sharing this time
with you if you guys had a good time
please give us a comment below we would
love to hear your thoughts we'd love to
build the community of conversation
let's do that together
also you like you guys know we always
say go create after watching this
content go create go make your own blogs
your own artistic renders your own
videos start your own businesses going
create create create go and make cool
things build cool things of value and
meaning into the world thank you to our
producer director much love to you Ron
and thank you everyone for tuning and we
greatly appreciate it we'll see you guys
soon
peace